judge jeanine pirro is going to be a
full-time co-host on the show and
geraldo rivera harold ford jr and
jessica tarlov will be our permanent
rotating co-host the changes officially
kick in starting january 24th harold and
jessica along with is that baby cleo
yeah i want to see the baby
on the screen
oh leo
oh she's big okay
she's we're big she's big
everyone's big
sleepy congratulations to all of you let
me start with harold what have you
gotten yourself into
i hope a good thing i've been watching
the show tonight and uh taking notes on
with haraldo's performance and uh i hope
we now can collaborate a little bit more
because those guys are tough
they are it's great to have you geraldo
you've you've watched this show from the
beginning are you excited to become a
officially a part of it
first of all a huge fan of jessica and
harold and of course you all have been
so kind to me uh you know despite the
fact that we obviously disagree on some
uh some poor issues but we agree we
agree that uh you know we we respect
each other we have great affection and i
think it comes across and that's why the
show's so successful dan i'm proud to be
on it jessica um
first of all it's great to see you with
this lovely baby
are you ready to get back in the arena
here and have some arguments with jesse
i was listening to the show as well i i
could i'm gonna use my last eight weeks
for sure before
coming back into the arena and i was
thrilled to see that jesse's new year's
resolution was to be nicer to me i have
a child i deserve that um but i'm really
thrilled uh to be joining the show it's
obviously a show watched for years and
i've been thrilled to be colleagues with
all of you and newer with harold
who joined just last year um but it's
great to be part of the show that really
shows off that people on both sides of
the aisle can get along and have fun and
um yeah i'm just overwhelmed by this and
this is
good
and judge jeanine let's give you a
chance to say a few words to the
audience here that that adores you well
first of all i'm i'm thrilled to be a
part of this i mean i love all of you
and uh it is for me an opportunity to do
a lot of things five days a week i mean
i've been on the weekends for 11 years
now everybody with justice with judge
janine and it's nice to be a part of a
team that discusses every big issue
every day five days a week so i'm
thrilled to be a part of this and i have
great respect uh for everyone here and
affection as well uh so for me it's it's
a wonderful thing my three dogs though
uh they're very upset about it worried
yes they'll be well taken care of though
greg you have anything you want to say
here to these folks i'm just i'm a
little bit worried about their choice of
music so like will i just have fewer
punk rock fewer metal songs and it'll
just be more country music i love
country i noticed that judge janine
chose little toby keith i think today
and jesse give you a last word here i'm
just gonna
i'm so excited i want to get back to the
table yeah because the best part about
this crew here is the conversations in
the commercial break geraldo's new
bentley or you know talking golf with
harold ford jr um or you know my giving
jessica nursing tips and
uh talking to the judge about new york
city and our dogs i can't wait to get
back to the table yeah okay well it's
thrilling it's a wonderful amazing show
i i know that the three of us are
honored to be on it and now we have all
of you with us as well and thank you to
all the fill ins as well
everybody we love you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else